chandler jones this appeared on the
arizona cardinals twitter account
uh last hour this is a a shot of j.j
watt going back and forth with chandler
jones uh or i guess chandler was sending
it to jj while that looks like instagram
to me right christopher
instagram story that chandler and jj
were having with each other
and chandler offered to be his if you
come here i'll be your personal chef
monday and wednesdays are free jj sent
back some crying emojis
and now um i guess chandler then sent it
to jj
what put this he posted what do you want
to eat lol
and then jj watt responded beef
wellington
so there's beef wellington all beef
wellington all around
orange whips beef wellington's all
around
and the man who's putting together that
defensive line for beef wellington's all
around as the general manager of the
arizona cardinals back here in the rich
housing show steve kahn how are you
steve
rich doing great beef wellington all
around huh
absolutely you know me rich i wouldn't
turn it down
oh okay i feel like this is is this an
annual tradition now like you make some
big huge springtime maneuver you come on
the show i guess that's what it is
deandre
it's got to be a texan too i guess
that's what it's got to be that's it's a
new tradition
hope we can keep it up well i don't want
to get you charged with tampering so
let's let's leave it right there
uh so my gosh steve when when did you
first start uh chit-chatting with j.j
watt
about him coming aboard well as soon as
he was uh
officially released uh you know
immediately took a look at the film and
um had not evaluated him in a number of
years for six reasons
through on the tape played over a
thousand snaps all 16 games and
um refreshed my memory that he still
looks like jj y
which was exciting i mean disruptive
quickness is still there powerful has a
great repertoire of rush moves and
so not only that you know obviously um
did some investigative work and talk to
guys like hop
and other people i knew that used to be
with texans organization
obviously vance joseph our defensive
coordinator coach jj at one time in
houston so
had some intimate knowledge and the fact
that um
you know i had that information along
with um the tape that i saw
um gave me the opportunity to reach out
to his representative r.j gosner who
i've known for years and
let him know our level of interest and
your level of interest was
uh communicated in a contract dollars
and cents and what have you
um how long did so so that happened um
almost immediately in terms of viewing
the game film
how long has there been an offer on the
table from arizona
to him that he said yes to steve well i
mean it was you know
first offer was i think after a few days
and
again really uh when you look at jj's
history i mean the guy's never been
recruited you know a walk-on in central
michigan and
um the path that he's taken i think it
was probably fairly exciting for him to
to have a number of teams recruit
him uh i certainly pulled out all the
stops guys like our friend frank
caliendo and hop and
even your new jingle blake shelton
okay how did caliendo help how did
caliendo help
in this process he probably impersonated
john gruden and
said that steve kyle had interest and
made some sort of funny
deal i don't know what he did but he was
my son's flag football coach
and a terrible one at that but he um
he uh lives right around the corner from
our facility and is a good friend as you
know so
he's always willing to help 16-0 man
that's what it sounds like okay very
good okay
wow fantastic and i i i guess blake had
something to do with it because we saw
his tweet
um yesterday um where he
was celebrating welcoming j.j watt i'll
be fielding all
inquiries on behalf of you you mentioned
steve kim our first statement is as
follows quote unquote other teams can
suck it
that was something steve i'm always
trying to keep it at the g
level level but uh you know blake sort
of has a mind of his own
hey he's he's blake shelton for crying
out loud
so how did you how did you employ him
did he did he call up jay
he you had him call up jj or he did that
on his own he'll make some
some videos recruiting videos for me so
he's he's
uh he's not a fair weather fan he is all
in
no kidding so this is like college this
is kind of like college
stuff that you you pulled off here steve
yeah right there's no doubt i mean you
have to do what you can rich
so um how fired up are you
i mean what what do you think this is
gonna portend for you
steve really excited especially the
opportunity to play beside chandler
jones and
i mean i think when you look at the the
numbers uh speak for itself i mean
since 2012 two guys that have led the
nfl and sacks
and uh to have those guys teamed up side
by side
um and not only what he brings to the
table as a player but
just his infectious personality um you
know the accountability that he brings
to our locker room
day in and day out that that's to me
what is is really exciting
you know his attention to detail um for
the game i mean when you talk to him i
mean it just oozes out of him his
ability to key and diagnose things and
how he you know reads offensive football
and schematics and stuff like that so
not only is he gonna uh be a good player
for us he is to me going to make the
players
around him a much better team he's a
bona fide star man in every
possible way steve and um and so
to add him to the mix you're also
getting somebody though who's got a
window
and that's you got to love that too
right he's got he's looking this is a
window you gave him two years and you
know
that he's this is it like he this is for
him this is
this is a a new best shot certainly
after a 44
win season that's got to be something
you enjoy
uh employing on your turf as well i
would imagine
absolutely and i mean that's that's the
flexibility when you have a rookie
quarterback
under that type of contract you know
that gives us that flexibility right now
until
uh hopefully we have to pay kyler a lot
of money meaning that he has played
exceptionally well and so far a guy that
won rookie of the year and went to the
pro bowl this year he's
he's on the right path steve kim general
manager of the arizona cardinals here on
the rich eisens show day after it
becomes official that j.j watt
is an arizona cardinal and another thing
that jj brings to the equation is that
beautiful patch that's on the front of
his jersey which is one of the most
incredible patches in all of sports and
honor to wear the walter payton man of
the year award the question is is
how many of those players with those
patches you're going to have on the
field next year which is my
sort of way to ask about larry
fitzgerald's future steve to just hit
the nail
that's a great question you know we i
have not talked to larry uh you know
we've given him his space and that sort
of thing and i think that's the
you know level of respect that that he's
earned and um
you know obviously love to have him back
but that decision is up to larry and
and hopefully we'll hear from him soon
what is the time frame on that
do you think steve uh we have no time
frame i mean i haven't given larry a
time frame i know michael talks to him
as well regularly so
um we'll just continue to monitor the
situation and
hopefully makes a decision soon michael
being the pilot who picked up
uh j.j watt how about another part of
the recruiting play yeah we'll just
send the pilot in the jet to get you
take that robert kraft
you fly a plane right this is basically
what you're saying
exactly exactly he really picked he
really
he really piloted the plane to pick up
jj and his wife is that really what
happened that really he did
and i think that shocked jj he said last
night at dinner you know
i can't believe when he showed up he
just said i just flew the plane here i
mean it's
and that's uh you know michael's
passionate about flying and
um so obviously it was a comfortable
ride for for jj and
yes i would say so feel free to
roam about the cabin um and and so so
uh when you say michael's spoken to he
speaks to larry
um does no does jj not speak to i mean
honestly i know you don't want to put
too much
pressure on it but how amazing would
that be to do you think there's a
shot or you know knowing larry he could
have made his mind up before week one
last year and
he's already made it up right now i mean
no i mean i think there's always a shot
i mean the competitor larry is and the
way we finish this season
um you know from all the good strides
that we've made
made in you know increasing with three
wins and all the positives that were
taken away
i think larry probably sees some some
great things moving forward but
you know certainly up to how he feels in
his body at this point in his career
steve khan general manager of the
arizona cardinals here on the rich eisen
show what else what else is on your sh
what's on your to-do list here now that
we've hit the second day of march and
you've got jj watt already in the fold
what's on your to-do
list well a number of things i mean just
preparing for free agency and
you know the obstacles with no nfl
combine that i know you've always
enjoyed this it's
uh tough for us but we you know through
um
you know through the virtual world we're
able to to still line up uh
individual meetings with these prospects
and talk to them through
um you know uh zoom or the virtual
world and and that and that's been you
know helpful as well
okay so you're that's that's where i
mean shoot we'd be in indianapolis right
now
i think yeah so like this morning i had
a slotted number of players and i'll
have that this afternoon where
they come in one by one and we'll talk
to them for about 20 minutes and
and uh get some good background
information and get to know him as
people
and then uh figure out your board look i
know you don't probably won't like
talking about this publicly but the the
passcode for that zoom
is eyes and 40 with the e-capitalized
right correct
and you will remain the screen saver on
our draft board i promise
i i would be so heartbroken steve if if
that
if if that never never never
never never never doesn't happen you
know what i mean i know i just i just
went
19 double negatives right there but um
okay so then that there's that then
there's free agency but um
what what are your needs i mean the way
that things ended last year
obviously uh the hail murray was a
a high point that you thought you could
build off of and then
everything else kind of went the wrong
way after that i mean what
what does a general manager of a team
under that circumstance do right now
like what are your goals what are you
looking for that you can share with me
here
well on the college side obviously
stacking the board um how we see those
guys
uh from a talent perspective and then
just the free agency part of it you know
there's a number of our own players that
we'd like to resign obviously the mark t
market will dictate whether we can have
them back or not um
but you know that'll be a part of it you
know we'd like to have um
those guys sort of take precedent and
then any of the areas that we can't fill
in
um with our own players you know
obviously
approach free agency with an aggressive
mindset trying to make this team better
and
it's going to be an interesting market
because of the down cap and and we'll
see how that goes could be a number of
one-year deals that a
number of people have reported about so
that part of it will be
uh interesting you know as we get
through the first two days of that
negotiation period
uh prior to the first day of free agency
what are you going to get that cap
number when are you going to get that
what's your expectation on that yeah
hopefully soon
i mean you know a couple million each
way you know really does matter i mean
that's a that can be a
starting player a role player that uh
that you're certainly fond of
well what have you been told what have
you in your comments i haven't been told
anything i thought maybe that you would
check in with me i got nothing
i got nothing steve i got nothing no
seriously i've
i've got zero uh i've got that and i i i
don't know i mean so did do you call
like
up michael bidwell when he's not flying
new free agency to say hey
lobbing a call or 345 park avenue like
what's uh are
are we waiting for them to to you know
take three billion a year out of disney
or something for monday night football
to figure this thing out i'm serious
like is that really good
what's it play just really until we get
word from the league i mean we're
operating from the standpoint that the
floor is 180 um and that's the
information we have so
you know we have to operate that way
right now and project moving forward and
anything
above and beyond that is to me icing on
the cake and what have you been told
about the draft is that going to be
all virtual again where everybody's in
their their home settings as well what
have you been told on that front about
i have again i haven't been told on that
um you know
to me i i know that uh you know we can't
take this lightly it's it's great to see
uh the numbers are decreasing rapidly it
sounds like
from all the reports i've seen so
hopefully we can get to a point where we
can have a
go back to normalcy but you know until
uh until i hear anything
uh further i'll be prepared to handle it
both ways okay
all right steve i appreciate the call so
um just and give break this news to me
gently
uh when you had blake shelton call jj
watt or do something for j.j watt he
didn't
he didn't write a jingle for him either
did he or is that just for me
no that's just for you rich you are
certainly a priority for
not only blake shelton but for the
arizona cardinals i appreciate it
i appreciate it yeah no look i i hear
you you know
thank you very much there it is
rich eyes it is it's catchy you got to
admit that man it's
that is awesome you know what and then
again i i i assume and um this goes
without saying but i do want to give you
the floor on it that you are fired up
for bruce aaron's
right that he's got in that ring that
absolutely
he's like family to me i mean i you know
we spent five great years together
grew up 15 miles apart so remain very
close and
love him to death and so happy for him
and his family i know it it is pretty
pretty amazing that this is what's uh
that this is what's happening i know
that you would hope that you guys could
do it together but it is pretty cool to
see
him he's got that ring man and um and
he's like he just wants to keep doing it
and he's just doing it his own
way and it's he's it's phenomenal i just
love that guy
he's just so authentic and then all
those guys jason
was my assistant at one time todd bowles
todd bowles was here that's right well
steve look
best of luck on getting that for
yourself and um and jj watt is a huge
i guess my piece of mitochondria to use
his phrase on twitter the other day
being the powerhouse of the cell uh
congrats on getting him and let's
let's chat down the line before the
draft at least for sure thanks rich
right back
thank you steve thanks for doing it so
quickly i appreciate that steve kim
everybody
general hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here